welcome to the show in American news and
politics there are major groundbreaking
events only every few years so we've had
9/11 we've had the Iraq war passing
Obamacare the first black president an
ignorant reality show hosts being
elected president the National
legalization of gay marriage a president
impeached a few weeks ago it's a sort of
random and incomplete list but the idea
is the truly major news stories aren't
every day the Iran Fiasco that Donald
Trump is building up to including maybe
a war with Iran on the proverbial eve of
his re-election could be one of those
stories as Donald Trump is increasingly
unhinged desperate impeached and trying
to salvage a second term by any means
that he can concoct now as you may know
by now
last week Donald Trump ordered an
unauthorized this assassination of the
leader of the Iranian Kurds Kasim
soleimani his behavior is so turbulent
Trump's that is so volatile so manic and
disturbed that the primary allies of the
United States are now clearly and
publicly abandoning Trump on this issue
and by virtue of that abandoning the
United States on this issue we are going
to get into all of this today the Thins
justification for the assassination if
you can even call it a justification the
gaslighting and the lies that are being
told about soleimani including that he
was linked to 9/11 we're going to get to
all of it but I want to sort of start
with the consequences and one of those
is that many of our key allies including
the United Kingdom and Germany and
others are saying stop they're saying no
no no you can't do this we are not with
you if this is what you were going to do
the United Kingdom says that further
conflict is quote in none of our
interests that's not totally true I mean
it might be in Donald Trump's interests
if he thinks it will help him get
reelected and it actually may then it is
sort of in Trump's interest but it's in
very few other people's interests
certainly military contractors seem to
be pleased about what's going
on defense contractors Germany says that
this is potentially a quote dangerous
escalation they don't want it they are
not with Trump and the United States
France has been trying to restore sort
of logic and reason to the Iran nuclear
deal deal after Donald Trump
unilaterally and without any real reason
bailed on the deal and we did this
without consulting France either and
later we will get to Iran is now saying
they are totally out of the Iran nuclear
deal since Trump failed on it anyway so
things not going well there the
Secretary of State for European affairs
Amelie de maua Len told a French radio
station that any unilateral action by
the United States was dangerous we did
this without even telling our European
allies about this now later we'll get
into this maybe tomorrow
it appears that random guests at Donald
Trump's mar-a-lago Resort knew more
about what Donald Trump was doing in
Iraq to this Iranian leader than our own
congressional leadership and our own
European allies as former United States
Secretary of Defense Robert McNamara
once said if we had chosen during the
Vietnam era not to do things
unilaterally and without the support of
our allies we never would have gone into
Vietnam in the first place and there are
actually starting to be shades of
history on a few different fronts here
so first is Vietnam the unilateral way
in which Donald Trump seems willing to
approach Iran given his actions so far
with Kasim soleimani hint at Vietnam
that's one sort of shaded history the
propagandizing that we're already seeing
about it was an imminent threat
Soleimani was connected to 9/11 that is
reminiscent not a Vietnam but of Iraq
and we're going to talk about the the
similarities to the Iraq war propaganda
a little bit later on in the program
today this is all bad and the only thing
that the supporters of Donald Trump's
actions have and there are some on the
right and there are actually some on the
left believe it or not that are
defending the actions of Donald Trump
the only thing that
they have is soleimani was a bad guy
well nobody's denying that Soleimani was
responsible for the deaths of Americans
historically both at that's true
it is not justification here for what
Donald Trump has done it is not
justification for an unhinged unilateral
foreign policy
that immediately gets our longtime
allies to say oh no no we don't want
anything to do with what's going on
there and it seems that increasingly
Donald Trump is going to have the
support of American Republican senators
and that really may be all he needs to
get what he wants and to do what he
wants to do which again he sees as
something to distract from the fact that
he is an impeached president something
that is extremely embarrassing to him to
the extent that he's able to feel
embarrassment and that's a limited sense
and to the extent that he believes it
will help him to get reelected in 2020
so let's now having sort of gotten to
the consequences first which is our
allies are abandoning us let's get into
some of the sub stories on Trump Iran
this includes the propaganda this
includes information security
justification the legality the threats
of war crimes that Donald Trump is
casually making on Twitter a lot of
Iran's stuff on today's program which by
the way I'm going to get this later is
not at all profitable for me but I don't
want to get put the cart before the
horse we'll get to that a little bit
later let's start with the justification
for the assassination of Kasim soleimani
Donald Trump yesterday had a press
availability I guess we would call it at
the White House it this was before Iran
attacked two US military bases in Iraq
and it was a strange sort of gongshow
combination of rambling confusing and
dishonest and it's becoming increasingly
embarrassing to be a trump supporter now
to normal people that is I think within
their you know cult Trump supporters
were doing within the world of the cult
Trump supporter they're probably still
pretty outwardly happy with their choice
at least as far as they're willing to
admit but when you see
Donald Trump behaved in this way make no
sense tell lies inaccuracies look
confused and disheveled this has to be
embarrassing for a Trump supporter right
or are they so cognitively dissonant
that they even see this and think wow
that's who I'm voting for for
re-election let's look at some clips
Donald Trump was first asked what did
you know about soleimani when you
decided to assassinate him and this is
an important question because we've
since learned since the assassination
we've learned that Donald Trump
essentially knew nothing about Kaseem
soleimani
but he was reportedly talked into the
assassination by some of the people
around him even though it had originally
been presented by the Pentagon as quote
the crazy option that they were offering
not expecting that he would take it and
Donald Trump confirms it in this first
clip he really knew nothing about Kasim
soleimani Eric about what evidence you
had the Qasem Soleimani was planning
attacks against American targets what
can you tell us about what you knew
prior to or during the attack well
number one I knew the past his past was
horrible he was a terrorist he was a so
designated by President Obama as you
know and he wasn't even supposed to be
outside of his own country he was so
right there but that's in a way the
least of it we had an attack very
recently that he was in charge of where
we had people horribly wounded one dead
in fact the number now as of this
morning I believe is two dead and that
was his he was traveling with the head
of Hezbollah they weren't there to
discuss a vacation they weren't there to
go to a nice resort someplace in Baghdad
they were there to discuss bad business
and we saved a lot of lives by
terminating his life a lot of lives have
saved they were planning something and
you're going to be hearing about it or
at least various people in Congress are
going to be hearing about it tomorrow
our Secretary of State covered it very
well a little while ago I saw him I saw
his news conference but so this is the
same razor-thin justification that
they've been parroting for several days
and you'll see later in a clip with Mike
Pompeo that they've all
shifted to a different justification for
the Kaseem soleimani assassination but
we'll get to that Donald Trump then in
the same press avail is asked about his
threat of war crimes Donald Trump
remember on Twitter threatening to
target Iranian cultural heritage sites
and here's what he had to say mr.
president whether irani and cultural
sites would be on any future target well
as I said yesterday was very interesting
they're allowed to kill our people
they're allowed to maim our people
they're allowed to blow up everything
that we have and there's nothing to stop
them and we are according to a various
laws supposed to be very careful with
their cultural heritage and you know
what if that's what the law is I like to
obey the law but think of it they kill
our people they blow up our people and
then we have to be very gentle with
their cultural institutions but I'm ok
with it it's ok with me
oh these laws they say we have to be so
careful we have to be gentle but
importantly notice that Donald Trump is
now backtracking saying ok we will obey
the law I guess the war crimes have been
canceled by Donald Trump good thing
yesterday I told you that the Pentagon
immediately said yeah Trump's suggesting
we target Iranian cultural sites we
wouldn't do that the Pentagon
immediately saying that's not something
that they would do then it got really
weird as if what we've seen so far isn't
weird enough Donald Trump was asked
about the Greek population in the United
States check out what he had to say so
Greece and I and my people and we have a
whole group of people and as you see
they've brought a lot of great
representatives from Greece that we've
been dealing with
we have a tremendous Greek population
over 3 million people as I understand it
that's fantastic I think I know I really
feel I know most of them I think I know
all of them come to think of it but it's
a great population in the United States
we're going to be meeting we're going to
be talking we're going to be negotiating
and we're going to be making a lot of
deals Greece and I I love that had
Greece
he talks about grease and I the Greek
population is tremendous now a quick
fact check there are not three million
Greek people in the United States the
number is less than half that 1.4
million Americans are of Greek descent
now that can be sort of vague only about
320,000 people in the u.s. above age
five speak Greek at home as of a few
years ago but never let the facts get in
the way of a good hyperbolic ramble and
then Donald Trump for good measure
repeats the complete and total lie that
he was strongly against the Iraq war
remember he was not strongly against the
Iraq war but here is Donald Trump
repeating this yet again let's see we
don't want to be there forever we want
to be able to get out I didn't want to
be there in the first place to be honest
and everybody knows that that was when I
was a civilian I said it but we were
there and they made a decision and I
disagreed with that decision very
strongly but we're there now we've done
a great job we've gotten rid of the
caliphate 100% of the Caliphate is gone
now here is Donald Trump saying that he
was in favor of the Iraq war on the
Howard Stern Show in 2002 I've played
this clip for you before and it is
particularly relevant here I know
they're skulking around somewhere and
you just feel like you're a sitting duck
but we have an idea what the enemy is
and a lot of times the politicians don't
want to tell you that are you from
vaiting Iraq yeah I guess so you know I
wish it was I wish the first tackle was
done correctly are you still against
rebuilding the World Trade Center I'm
not against rebuilding yeah I said very
clearly not a guy who was against the
Iraq war so it's exhausting to keep up
with it all it never makes any sense
it's a mess it's a worldwide
laughingstock and meanwhile Donald Trump
always seems to be a few talking points
behind on these things because now
Donald Trump's own Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo has come up with a new
justification for assassinating Kasim
Soleimani that's actually even more
incoherent than the one Trump gave
remember the initial justification for
the assassination of the Iranian codes
leader that started this entire thing
including two US military bases being
bombed last night was a justification
based on the imminency of an attack
and by Kaseem soleimani based on what he
was doing now and donald trump parroted
that during his press avail but then
here is Mike Pompeo talking about oh no
the justification is a tax that took
place some times in the past which is a
completely different explanation the
opportunity that we thought might
present itself at some point and we
could see clearly that not only had
sulemani done all of the things that we
have recounted right hundreds of
thousands of massacre in Syria enormous
destruction of countries like Lebanon
and Iraq where they've denied them
sovereignty in the Iranian have really
denied people in those two countries
what it is they want right sovereignty
independence of freedom is this is also
lamanna's handiwork and then we'd watch
as he was continuing the terror campaign
in the region we know what happened at
the end of last year in December
ultimately leading to the death of an
American so a shift from it was an
imminent threat which has been widely
debunked because there was no evidence
of presented with that - this was really
more punishment for things that were
done in the past the reason they can't
get their stories straight is because
none of the stories make sense and this
was all framed up as an attempt by
Donald Trump to distract from
impeachment and - as he sees it helped
him in his re-election campaign in an
election that is now just about ten and
a half months away this is going to
continue getting worse unless an adult
can get into the room and make sure that
it doesn't it's not clear that that's
going to happen we'll keep following it
and by the time you listen to or watch
this clip Trump may have bombed Iran we
just cannot predict what is going to
happen next so we've been covering
what's going on in Iran and part of that
story includes that yesterday Donald
Trump casually threatened war crimes
against Iran on Twitter threatening
Iranian cultural sites as targets which
is a war crime per the Geneva Convention
it's very cut and dry there's really no
ambiguity about that the question is are
the threats going to become actual
orders and if they become orders what is
the Pentagon what is the military
actually going to do we have some good
news
if we can believe it and the
believability of it is something we'll
talk about in a second and the good news
is that the Pentagon immediately said no
we are not going to commit Donald
Trump's war crimes Secretary of Defense
mark Esper admitted yesterday I mean he
didn't even try to deny that targeting
Iranian cultural sites if they are not
otherwise military targets targets of
military value crazy world we live in
right if there is not a standalone
military value to the cultural sites it
would be a war crime and that they would
not do it and this puts mark espera and
the Pentagon directly opposite Trump who
insists that these are legitimate
targets and actually double down on the
war crime threat on Air Force One when
asked about is completely unhinged
tweets the Secretary of Defense mark
Esper said quote we will follow the laws
of armed conflict now for like a split
second I kind of felt bad for a second
for the people that have to deal with
Donald Trump and clean up his messes and
then I remembered hey choosie you can
choose whatever job you want they can
quit at any time and then I didn't feel
bad for them anymore but military
leaders are in a position where they
have to balance the law and reality and
empiricism with what Donald Trump wants
and what Donald Trump tweets and Donald
Trump often loses it when he does not
get what he wants Donald Trump
threatening war crimes on Twitter
appears to be disturbing not just
international allies which we talked
about yesterday but it's disturbing even
our own military and our Pentagon and
the Secretary of Defense so I have a few
thoughts on this number one if indeed
the Pentagon is honest in what they say
like if we can trust mark Esper is
telling the truth when he says we're not
going to do it these are war crimes then
that's good
but can we believe mark Esper are they
just saying this because historically
the United States doesn't announce one
way or the other when its military is
going to be committing war crimes we
often find out later many times thanks
to investigative journalism document
leaks
sometimes FOIA requests are part of it
so this is sort of uncharted territory
where in advance the president is saying
here's an idea let's commit some war
crimes I have a list of war crimes
targets that I would like to see
targeted and then the Secretary of
Defense says no those would be war
crimes we're not going to do it this is
a very backwards way in which this
normally happens but it's conceivable
that getting this out into the open
ahead of time actually makes it less
likely by shining a spotlight on it that
it eventually happens now to keep going
with this if Mark espera is telling the
truth and he can be believed that the
Pentagon the military will not be
committing the war crimes that Donald
from threatened is Mark espers job safe
because we've seen that when a trump
administration official publicly
contradicts the word of Trump very often
they end up resigning force resignations
and Donald Trump pulls in someone who is
much more willing to do his bidding or
at least shut the hell up about it and
not make it clear that they disagree
with Donald Trump number three
think about how insane things are today
that it is newsworthy that the Pentagon
is ruling out war crimes preemptively as
suggested by the president on Twitter
this is the reality this is a headline
today in 2020 number four the fact that
Donald Trump even threatened these war
crimes is still disgraceful and
potentially an escalating action and
Donald Trump is quickly moving from
being an international laughingstock to
being an international terror and number
five let's not excuse the Republican
Party at large we're going to talk later
in the show about how 20 people or even
14 people in the Senate and cabinet
respectively could put an end to the
worldwide fiasco that is Donald Trump
we'll get to that later not a single
Republican member of the House or Senate
have just said I condemn Donald Trump
casually threatening war crimes on
Twitter not a single one not one
Republican and that's part of why we're
in
is trouble that's part of why this guy
might get himself reelected now to get
back to the war crimes for a moment what
will happen if Donald Trump gives the
order does Marquez per se no do the
general say no in the United States
military orders are only considered
valid if they are legal if they adhere
to the United to the Uniform Code of
Military Justice the UCMJ that's a
separate branch of legal code and all US
military personnel are under oath to
follow that there's also the LOA see the
law of armed conflict there's the Geneva
Conventions and according to
international humanitarian law and I
think with many trumpets if you say to
them international humanitarian law they
just laugh right I mean they don't care
about that according to international
humanitarian law officers are not to be
punished if they refuse to carry out
orders that are known or suspected to be
illegal an order to intentionally target
cultural sites and cultural objects and
locations lacking military value would
absolutely fall under illegal under that
umbrella I don't know what we would
expect to happen technically illegal
orders are supposed to be disobeyed or
the perpetrator can be held accountable
just like that person giving the order
and in fact there's historical precedent
from this you can go back to World War
Two and the I was just following orders
defense is one that is not valid so I I
don't know we're now getting sort of
it's hugely depressing that we're even
getting into this conversation to this
degree but this is the world in 2020
under Donald Trump we have an
opportunity to end at least part of it
just ten months from now I hope that we
will take that opportunity we'll get a
little bit later in the program to the
spineless Republicans 14 of whom could
end this national tragedy and are
choosing not to do that but first let's
talk about Democrats trying anyway to
control Donald Trump on Iran we know
broken clocks can be right twice a day
but they can be wrong for they can be
right for the wrong reason better said
and that's exactly what happened
with FoxNews propagandist Tucker Carlson
after the Trump Iran Fiasco got underway
with the unauthorized assassination of
Iranian Kurds leader Kasim soleimani
Tucker Carlson correctly pointed out
maybe Iran is not the greatest threat we
face may be Americans wouldn't benefit
from escalating a war with Iran maybe we
have our own issues to deal with here in
the United States now of course the
issues
Tucker thinks we need to deal with in
the United States are very different
from the issues you and I likely think
we need to deal with in the United
States but Tucker has this sort of anti
interventionist side and he is correctly
pointing out on Fox News that this
doesn't make a shred of sense take a
look threats in the region if you don't
live in Washington here's the
translation that would be in hostile
Middle Eastern countries places where
American troops would never be in the
first place we're not for the insistent
demands of non geniuses like max boot
and John Bolton but nevermind no one in
Washington is in mood for big-picture
questions right now questions the
obvious ones like is Iran really the
greatest threat we face and who's
actually benefitting from this and why
are we continuing to ignore the decline
of our own country in favor of jumping
into another quagmire from which there
was no obvious exit by the way if we're
still in Afghanistan 19 years sad years
later what makes us think there's a
quick way out of Iran and so on nobody
is thinking like that right now instead
chest beaters like senator Ben Sasse of
Nebraska are making the usual warlike
noises the ones they always make this is
very simple Ben Sasse wrote in a
statement last night general Soleimani
is dead because he was an evil bastard
who murdered Americans which is
essentially true Soleimani was certainly
a bad guy but does that make killing him
quote very simple it does not nothing
about life and certainly nothing about
killing is ever very simple in any
politician tells you otherwise is dumb
or is lying
yes Soleimani was linked to the deaths
of Americans nobody mourns his passing
but Mexico and China are also linked to
the deaths of Americans each has flooded
our country with narcotics from which
tens of thousands of Americans die every
single year not that
in power cares so does that mean we get
to bomb Oaxaca
can we start assassinating generals in
the People's Liberation Army
maybe maybe Ben Sasse will call for that
too he's a former consultant a very
tough character tucker carlson is spot
on that nothing will be quick or easy
there will be no solving a problem by
invading Iran there will be nothing
simple about assassinating a leader like
Kasim soleimani and saying hey great we
did it we have a horrible track record
of being totally unable to end conflicts
that often make no sense to begin with
and Tucker Carlson agrees with me and
with many people that Kasim soleimani
was a bad guy but the idea that we
should assassinate him and then escalate
a military conflict with Iran is a
terrible idea
there are right-wingers who are
experiencing some cognitive dissonance
here because they see Trump really wants
it but another pseudo hero of theirs
Tucker Carlson doesn't want it what do
we do what do we do this is where you
need to be able to think for yourself
this is an unauthorized assassination
which if you believe in checks and
balances has to be opposed period this
is the possible lead up for political
purposes to another endless conflict
very expensive one where the winners are
military contractors the war hawks maybe
Trump getting reelected and the losers
are all the people that will die
Americans who are seeing their tax money
spent on political conflicts rather than
on improving the United States merely
it's like we don't have to go look for
proposals for how to improve things
we've got proposals on healthcare and
education and so many other things
even if you hate Iranian leadership and
what Iran stands for and the religious
theocracy that exists there you still
have to be against this but then of
course Tucker Carlson goes on to say we
have our own issues issues to deal with
a lot of the issues he wants to deal
with are horrible examples of his
xenophobia Tucker Carlson has talked
about the hoax of white supremacy it's
not a hoax it's a real issue we've got
to deal with in the United States
he thinks it's fake tucker has talked
about how immigrants coming to our
country
make us a dirtier country
he wants to deal with that we don't
think that's actually an issue we find
that extremely xenophobic and racist
he's saying the right things but for the
wrong reasons the issues he wants to
focus on domestically are ones that
serve his reactionary agenda like
stopping immigration to the United
States by brown people and even in the
clip he eventually talks about how bad
Mexico is Mexico is not bad in the way
that many of our adversaries are bad
people in Mexico are functioning
primarily out of desperation and because
of corruption and economic realities if
we really want to deal with Mexico we
would deal with the reasons that drugs
and people come here in the first place
that's not Tucker's view he's wrong on
this issue but even Tucker Carlson
recognizes the folly of what Donald
Trump is doing here with Iran I wish he
would call Trump out instead of just
calling out Ben Sasse and Mike Pompeo I
wish he would call out the completely
politically opportunistic nature of this
which is immoral at its core and he
doesn't but even if Tucker Carlson
pierces the echo chamber of just a few
of the Fox News viewers that are
watching him this is still a very good
thing that being said I would not be at
all surprised to eventually see Tucker
Carlson kind of fall back to some kind
of mild deference to Donald Trump in
general I'd also love to see Tucker the
fiscal conservative that he claims to be
call out that no one is asking how would
we pay for this war in Iran I would not
agree with him on all of the things I
mentioned earlier but I would respect
Tucker Carlson a little bit if he
actually called out the so-called
fiscally conservative right and said
guys we can't just talk about can we
afford it
when it's health care and education
we've got to talk about it when it's
pointless politically opportunistic wars
as well I'm not holding my breath for
Tucker Carlson to do that war with Iran
may be escalating or it may not be we
don't know but what I can tell you is
that last night as I started an
impromptu livestream as we learned that
Iran had attacked two US bases in Iraq
it was feeling a whole hell of a lot
like that evening in 2003 when George
you Bush was president announcing that
we had started the war with Iraq Iran
has retaliated to Donald Trump's
assassination of the Iranian Kurds
leader Kasim Soleimani with missile
attacks on two US bases in Iraq this
includes the al-assad base and Erbil
which is another airbase this was very
much starting to feel like the beginning
of the Iran war although it's possible
that it won't happen and I'll explain
all of the possibilities momentarily it
has not yet escalated in that way but as
I watched the videos of the missiles
last night seeing the live news coverage
brought me back to the start of the Iraq
war right now we are not aware of any
casualties whether Donald Trump now does
or does not react is a materially
relevant foreign policy decision but
it's also related to some pretty clever
strategy by Iran thanks to Donald Trump
being so trigger Abul and so arrogant
and so egoistic and I'm going to explain
that because that really Trump's
personality could be the one factor that
determines whether this becomes the Iran
war or whether this stops here so let's
go through this step-by-step because
it's really important to understand the
comings and goings because this could be
an on-ramp to full-scale war or it could
be an off-ramp from further escalation
so Donald Trump ordered the
assassination of the Iranian codes
leader we've already covered this Kasim
soleimani who was assassinated without
congressional authorization which Donald
from previously claimed presidents do
need to have Iran threatened to
retaliate and Donald Trump went to
Twitter and said if you do we will
escalate remember Donald Trump tweeting
quote Iran is talking very boldly about
targeting certain USA assets has
revenged for our ridding the world of
their terrorist leader who had just
killed an American and badly wounded
many others not to mention all of the
people he had killed over his lifetime
including recently hundreds of Iranian
protesters he was already attacking our
embassy and preparing for additional
hits in other locations most of this
appears to be untrue by the way Iran has
been nothing but problems for many years
let this serve as a warning
that if her on strikes any Americans or
American assets we have targeted 52
Iranian sites some at a very high level
and important to Iran and the Iranian
culture and those targets and Iran
itself will be hit very fast and very
hard the USA wants no more threats so
Donald Trump among threatening war
crimes their pre committed to further
action if Iran retaliates so Iran did
retaliate
two strikes yesterday hit hitting two
different military bases in Iraq
although seemingly without any
casualties launching more than a dozen
missiles claiming that every missile hit
its target despite not killing anybody
now this was deliberate in the sense
that it was calculated this was a
sophisticated move by Iran if Donald
Trump does not want further escalation
Iran didn't kill anybody there are some
reports alleging that these attacks were
communicated ahead of time through a
proxy to the United States to ensure
that there would be no casualties at
these bases so that Iran can get a
retaliation on paper save face as the
case may be without actually killing
anybody and without forcing Donald Trump
to escalate further if he chooses not to
and in fact iran's Foreign Minister
Javad Zarif who also tweets foreign
policy said quote Iran took and
concluded proportionate measures in
self-defense under article 51 of UN
Charter targeting base from which
cowardly armed attack against our
citizens and senior officials were
launched we do not seek escalation or
war but we'll defend ourselves against
any aggression
this is actually an olive branch to
trump in the form of a possible off-ramp
if trump actually does not want more
escalation this is a move by iran that
allows trump to stop here because iran
didn't kill anybody
this Iran this Iranian attack does not
force Donald Trump's hand if Donald
Trump is determined to escalate he's
going to do it anyway now this is where
it gets bizarre yesterday in the midst
of all this Donald Trump tweeted during
the livestream that we were doing quote
all as well missiles launched from Iran
at two military bases located in her
assessment of casualties and damage is
taking place now so far so good we have
the most powerful and well-equipped
military anywhere in the world by far I
will be making a statement tomorrow
morning this goes way too far this is
way too casual it's way too upbeat it's
almost like oh cool we're gonna have
bagels and smoked salmon as well because
this is all just so fun and we're all
having a great time I was actually
wondering whether this was even Donald
Trump or someone else may have taken his
phone and tweeted this all is well is
the phrase of someone who either is in
way over their head is completely
intimidated by the more sophisticated
strategic decisions being made by the
Iranians or is simply gaslighting people
my understanding of Donald Trump's
personality and ego make it very
difficult to imagine that he won't want
to retaliate but my sense is that there
are people around Donald Trump including
probably Secretary of Defense Mark Esper
who do not want an escalation and
recognize that it is not actually
necessary here now let's tail back to
the tactics and strategy piece of all of
this I do believe that if Donald Trump
does not do further military hostilities
that Iran likely will also not do any
more that seems reasonable
the thing about Iran is that much
differently than Iraq Iran's cyber
warfare capabilities are significant
even if Iran's military does nothing
more in the military realm the cyber
realm becomes a real possibility and one
that Donald Trump's administration has
not taken seriously throughout the
presidency of Donald Trump key takeaways
number one this does not have to be the
start of World War 3 as some are calling
it or of the Iran war as others are
calling it but it depends on Donald
Trump and that's horrifying
the that the decision about whether or
not the United States enters a major
military conflict with a far better
equipped opponent than Iraq I'm not
saying they're better equipped in the
u.s. they are better equipped than Iraq
this particularly that that decision
rests on bogus political grounds really
primarily to help Donald Trump be
reelected and distract from impeachment
it is
horrifying that that's who and what this
depends on now I want to hear from
people in my audience people who watch
people who listen who want war with Iran
okay yesterday during our livestream we
had about 10,000 live viewers and save a
few obvious trolls and people who were
joking nobody says that this is a good
idea so if you support war with Iran not
because you think it'll help Trump get
reelected but if you think that there is
a worthwhile mission in going to war
with Iran tell me why you support it
what the targets would be what the goal
of this would be how would we know if
we've won and how long you expect it to
take okay I I want to hear from you if
you were in that camp lastly this is all
about politics and it's all about Donald
Trump so let's talk about that does a
war with Iran actually help Donald Trump
we know that the assassination of Kasim
soleimani was a political ploy to
distract from being an impeached
president and to start creating a
pretext to justify his own reelection
there's a rule of thumb there's a
conventional wisdom that wars are good
for incumbent presidents it allows them
to say let's not change horses midstream
it frames them as more presidential than
their opponent because not only are they
running for reelection they're also
managing a war so historically a
military conflicts have actually been
pretty good for the re-election of
presidents but will it work in this case
it's not clear to me that in this case
it would help Trump especially because
there seems to be very little support
for attacking Iran so I want to hear
from you about that as well would a war
with Iran actually help Donald Trump in
terms of his re-election let me know I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman follow me there
follow the show on Twitter at David
Pakman show and we are going to continue
talking about this later on today's
program and throughout the week as well
I anticipate during live calls on the
Friday show Iran will continue to be a
topic of much discussion quick break
back after this with much more so
everything that is happening around from
Barren is terrible there is the
possibility of learning something from
the
so and I want to take this opportunity
because there are lots of people in my
audience who may be too young to
remember the march to war with Iraq in
March of 2003 and in 2002 leading up to
the eventual invasion of Iraq in 2003
this was one of the first big political
events in my life so we had 9/11 in 2001
that and I remember that and then I
remember following and sort of
processing what was going on and
eventually we got to the lead-up to and
the eventual invasion of Iraq in 2003
during the George W Bush administration
one of the characteristics of the lead
up to the Iraq war was the
propagandizing about imminent threats
from Saddam Hussein Saddam was linked to
the 9/11 attacks of course that wasn't
true the reality at the time we later
found out was that the war in Iraq had
already been agreed upon in a sense it
had been pointed to as a target a decade
earlier when George HW Bush didn't get
done what he wanted to get done in Iraq
and then it was just a matter of
manufacturing enough public consent to
go ahead and do it and with 9/11 and
with : Powell and condi rice citing
bogus intelligence and saying we've got
to go it's an imminent threat it's time
to do it they were ultimately able to
manufacture enough consent to go and do
it we are seeing a very very similar
propaganda campaign now around Iran with
some key differences let's talk about
the differences number one Trump is not
george w bush without romanticizing
george w bush because he was a disaster
Donald Trump is much more unhinged than
Bush in terms of Bush at least felt the
need to fabricate a bogus case for going
into Iraq Donald Trump doesn't really
seem to feel the need to do that and you
will see that by virtue of how thin the
justification they're giving is another
important difference between Iran 2020
and Iraq 2003 is that the media today is
not what it was in 2003 Fox News was
around in 2003 I think in 96 Fox News
started but in 2003 Fox News was not
is now the social media echo chambers
that further manufacture consent were
nothing in 2003 compared to what they
are today so let's dig into this the
case that the White House is making for
why it made sense to without
authorization from Congress which Donald
Trump claimed when Barack Obama was
president was necessary for this type of
military action without even
communicating with congressional leaders
without even communicating with our
European allies Donald Trump says he
urgently had to go in and assassinate
Kasim soleimani because he was
imminently planning attacks against
American forces and diplomats in the
Middle East
no evidence has been presented so again
difference from 2003 in 2003 they
created all sorts of evidence much of
which we later found out was incorrect
in order to justify going into Iraq
Donald Trump is not even presenting any
evidence what they are saying is oh it
was just a minute it was imminent and it
all appears to be a lie to US officials
briefed about this say that the evidence
for assassinating Kasim soleimani is
quote razor thin that's diplomatic speak
for there is no real evidence we've just
created a speculative case based on some
isolated and irrelevant facts and we
know what those facts are according to
reporter Rukmini kalamaki the so-called
evidence was number one sole emani's
pattern of travel number two Sola manis
request to visit the Supreme Leader of
Iran to get approval for an operation it
could be anything and number three
Soleimani is allegedly more belligerent
position towards American interests in
Iraq this is not evidence of imminent
attacks this is not a good guy
we don't at any point it's important for
the left not to feel like we have to
defend Soleimani he was a bad guy he did
horrible things the question is by
Trump's own standards of requiring
congressional approval and not being a
bloodthirsty war monger was this the
right thing to do the answer is no we
then have much like with Saddam Hussein
in 2002 in 2003
the 911 card which has been pulled vice
president Mike Pence mentioned this
tweeting that Kasim soleimani
quote assisted in the clandestine travel
to Afghanistan of 10 to 12 10 of the 12
terrorists who carried out the September
11 terrorist attacks in the United
States this is so flaccid that you could
just blow and it would fall over like a
piece of paper remember that if
assisting in travel is evidence of
complicity in 9/11 the u.s. gave the
9/11 hijackers visas and allowed them to
come to the United States it's it's thin
in both cases and it is not actually
evidence of anything the 9/11 Commission
looked at allegations of Iran's
complicity in 9/11 no Iranian zhh were
involved there were no Iranian Zinn the
al Qaeda Network that carried out the
attack this is revisionist history and
we can't allow it and I feel like I'm
being transported back almost 20 years
to 2002 and the lead up to the Iraq war
lastly and I hate to say lastly because
this actually is a huge deal there is
still no serious legal basis for this
assassination that has been established
we will certainly be talking more about
the legal basis and that Fiasco later on
this week the consensus from many
foreign policy analysts and simply from
rational people able to think is that
this is exactly what Trump said Obama
would do but it's Trump who's doing it
Trump tweeted endlessly years ago that
Barack Obama in order to help himself
get reelected would go to war with Iran
we don't have to look far here look at
some of Donald Trump's old tweets quote
in order to get elected Barack Obama
will start a war with Iran quote now
that Obama's poll numbers are in a
tailspin watch for him to launch a
strike in Libya or Iran he is desperate
quote now that Obama's poll numbers are
in tailspin wata I'd already read that
one
there are many many more Obama didn't do
it Trump is impeached Trump is facing a
tough re-election it is abundantly clear
that one element here is Trump doing
this to distract from impeachment and
because he believes it will help him get
reelected in 2020 and I hate to admit
this it's really it's disgusting that I
I'd be lying if I didn't admit it
it actually might work if you have seen
how quickly most Republican senators and
almost all trumpets have fallen in line
and said hey listen this was a bad guy
Trump is big and strong he went and he
got him he's sending the message that
you cannot do this you cannot attack
American interests or people or assets
overseas or anywhere they are falling in
line much like many of the we will be
greeted as liberators crowd fell in line
behind the Iraq propaganda of : Powell
and Donald Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney and
of course George W Bush in 2002 in 2003
this might actually work and get Donald
Trump re-elected just ten months from
today we're going to keep talking about
this but in the meantime let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show